Macht New Work glücklich?
Dieser Frage
ging ich in meiner Reportage nach,
in der ich
ZEAM nach Berlin begleitete.
Ich kam da selbst
etwas in einen Zwiespalt,
und diesen Zwiespalt spürte ich auch
in den Kommentarspalten.
Willkommen zum "Q&A". Wir gehen nun
gemeinsam einige Kommentare durch.
Die ersten Kommentare
zeigen schon etwas,
was für ein Zwiespalt
da ausgelöst wurde.
Joshwirth schreibt:
Jamesvardy6826 schrieb daraufhin:
Das widerspiegelt etwas
diesen Zwiespalt.
Danke zunächst
für all eure Kommentare.
Letztlich geht es ja darum, über
das Thema New Work zu diskutieren.
Es kamen auch einige Fragen
von euch rein.
Diese möchte ich heute gerne mit
dem Experten Konrad Weber besprechen.
Er ist Strategieberater,
New-Work-Experte
und unterrichtet an der HWZ
ein CAS zu New Work.
Wir haben nun einen Call mit ihm.
Hallo, Konrad.
- Hallo.
Es kommentierten ja sehr viele Leute.
Ich pickte mir
einige Kommentare heraus,
die ich gerne
mit dir besprechen würde.
Der erste Kommentar
kommt von JonasGrossMusic.
Er schreibt:
Phil98053 schreibt:
Wie siehst du das?
Jedes Arbeitsmodell kann letztlich
toxische Züge annehmen.
Sei es ein klassisch hierarchisches,
oder eben ein neueres,
bei dem man
auf ausgeglichene Hierarchien,
auf andere, neuere Regeln setzt.
Ich finde es megawichtig, dies
immer wieder zum Thema zu machen
und im Team, im Unternehmen
darüber zu sprechen,
wie man eigentlich
zusammenarbeiten will.
Ich sehe das
nicht nur als New-Work-Problem,
sondern als ein grundsätzliches
Thema, das heutzutage -
bei steigendem
Zeit- und Leistungsdruck -
grundsätzlich in ganz vielen
Unternehmen zu beobachten ist.
In der Community
waren die Bedenken sehr gross,
dass bei New-Work-Konzepten
die Mitarbeitenden ausgenutzt werden,
gerade weil
die Arbeitszeiten so frei sind.
Junejames2888 ist ebenfalls kritisch:
Profitieren davon
wirklich die Mitarbeitenden
oder letztlich
doch eher die Inhaber/-innen?
Das Konzept
ist eigentlich schon relativ alt
in Anbetracht des ganzen Hypes,
der v.a. nach Corona um dieses Thema
aufgetaucht ist.
Es reicht zurück
bis in die 70er-, 80er-Jahre,
als es darum ging,
den Menschen vom klassischen
kapitalistischen Arbeitsmodell
etwas zu befreien.
Dass es mehr individuelle Auswahl
gibt, wie man arbeiten möchte
und wie die Arbeit
dein Leben bestimmt.
Darum war es ursprünglich
eigentlich etwas,
das sehr auf den Menschen
zentriert war.
Mittlerweile sieht man viele
unterschiedliche Ausprägungen davon.
Natürlich kann es für
ein Unternehmen auch spannend sein,
wenn jemand immer erreichbar ist,
von überall aus arbeiten kann.
Dass man das
von den Leuten verlangt,
kann durchaus auch
dem Unternehmen dienen,
denn so sind alle Leute
stets auf Abruf bereit.
Gleichzeitig muss das Unternehmen
keinen Pikettdienst
oder Wochenend-, Abend-
und Nachtzulagen bezahlen.
Umgekehrt besteht der Anreiz,
dass man mehr Freiheit hat,
sich die Zeit einteilen kann.
Es ist also ein Geben und Nehmen.
Judyrechsteiner2611 hat
folgenden Kommentar geschrieben:
Gibt es Techniken, wie man sich
bei New Work trotzdem abgrenzen kann,
wenn der Übergang zwischen
Arbeit und Freizeit so fliessend ist?
Wir alle konnten 2020 während
der einschneidenden Coronaphase,
als alle Hobbys und Freizeit-
aktivitäten wegfielen, beobachten,
dass man in dieser Zeit
nur noch arbeitete
und dann irgendwann schlafen ging
oder etwas auf Netflix schaute.
Diese Grenzen
verwischten sich damals stark.
Dieses Abgrenzen
hat man wohl schon stärker,
wenn man immer am selben Ort bleibt.
Da gibt es schon Techniken,
damit das einfacher fällt.
Wenn du die Möglichkeit hast,
solltest du sicher nicht
im Schlafzimmer arbeiten.
Denn das gibt dann
die grössten Schwierigkeiten.
Nach Möglichkeit
solltest du nach der Arbeit
etwas dazwischenschieben -
nach draussen gehen,
etwas mit den Händen machen,
kochen oder so.
Um sozusagen aus dem Kopf
und wieder in den Körper zu kommen,
damit du einen Break machen kannst.
Oder du sagst im Team ganz bewusst,
dass man sich zwar
zeitlich fix einteilen kann,
dass aber
um eine bestimmte Zeit Schluss ist
und dann auch nicht verlangt wird,
dass man noch auf Mails reagiert,
dass man nach wie vor
erreichbar sein muss.
Man sollte sich selbst
gewisse Grenzen setzen
und diese im Team besprechen, damit
sie von allen mitgetragen werden.
Der nächste Kommentar richtet sich
an die Inhaber/-innen von ZEAM.
Deshalb schrieb ich Jo, damit er
den Kommentar beantworten kann.
Jo antwortete mir darauf und sagt,
dass die Arbeitszeit bei ZEAM
normal sei,
die Flexibilität jedoch anders sei,
da man die Arbeit erledigen könne,
wann man wolle.
Manche Menschen würden lieber am
Morgen, andere in der Nacht arbeiten.
Bei ihnen mache das jede Person so,
wie es für sie am besten passt.
Den nächsten Kommentar
habe ich auch Jo geschickt.
Saer1371 schreibt:
Auch darauf antwortete Jo:
Er sagt, dass vielen jungen Leuten
Nachhaltigkeit wichtig sei,
auch ihnen von ZEAM.
Wenn möglich setzten sie
auf öffentliche Verkehrsmittel.
Das gelte v.a. für Kundenbesuche,
für Teamevents, z.B., als wir für
die Reportage nach Berlin gingen.
Oder für die Reise nach Italien,
die sie in zwei Wochen machen.
Aber mit dem Zug nach New York - das
sei natürlich nicht möglich gewesen.
In New York gebe es Sachen,
die man sonst nirgends finde.
U.a. hätten sie dort LinkedIn,
Tiktok und Snapchat besucht
und so wertvolle Informationen für
ihre Kunden nach Hause nehmen können.
Das waren die Fragen an Jo.
Somit kommen wir zur nächsten Frage,
die wieder dir gilt, Konrad Weber.
Jo sagt es in der Reportage
und ich spürte es auch stark,
als ich mit ZEAM in Berlin war.
Es ist schon nicht für alle
der passende Lifestyle,
das passende Arbeitsmodell.
Auch in den Kommentaren war man sich
einig, dass es nicht für alle ist.
Ist New Work nur etwas
für junge Menschen?
Das Beispiel von ZEAM,
das du aufgezeigt hast,
ist ein Extrembeispiel,
würde ich sagen.
Es wirkt wirklich so,
als sässen sie 24/7 aufeinander.
Erst recht
während dieser Workation in Berlin.
Es ist natürlich schon so:
Wenn du jünger bist,
bist du wohl eher bereit,
aufgrund dieses Gruppengefüges
auch mitzuziehen.
Vielleicht hast du dein privates
Umfeld eben auch bei der Arbeit,
da du viel Zeit zusammen verbringst.
Auch noch nach Feierabend.
Das verbindet extrem.
Aber sobald du
andere Verpflichtungen hast,
z.B. Kinder oder so,
wird es halt
ein grösseres Jonglieren.
Dann musst du auch Neinsagen können.
Adamcrapple6089
mit dem nächsten Kommentar:
Gibt es bei New Work
wirklich sektenartige Tendenzen?
Wenn man beobachtet, was du in
der Reportage von ZEAM gezeigt hast,
kann man durchaus
das Gefühl bekommen,
dass es
eine eingeschworene Truppe ist.
Es gibt auch sehr hohe Hürden,
um Teil davon zu sein.
Man kennst sich in- und auswendig.
Das sind alles Elemente,
dass man denken könnte,
dass es sich
um eine Sekte oder so handelt.
Es ist wichtig, zu differenzieren,
dass es nicht immer so sein muss.
Man kann gewisse Elemente
von New Work leben,
ohne sich mit Haut und Haar
in so etwas zu begeben.
Gewisse Abgrenzungen
sind durchaus möglich.
Niemand zwingt einen dazu,
früh am Morgen
gemeinsam Sport zu betreiben
oder gemeinsam ein Eisbad zu nehmen.
Aber ja, es schwingt sicher
ein gewisser Gruppendruck mit.
Und wenn sich dem manche Personen
immer wieder verwehren,
gehören sie vielleicht
dann nicht mehr so dazu.
Der andere Aspekt,
den wir gesehen haben:
Es sind sehr verschiedene Leute
mit unterschiedlichen Hintergründen,
und doch
ähneln sie sich alle vom Typ her.
Sie sind ähnlich alt,
stehen diesen Konzepten
ähnlich offen gegenüber.
Das zeigt auch etwas auf,
dass es ähnliche Menschen anzieht,
gerade bei so einem Unternehmen.
Das ist eine Realität,
die man akzeptieren muss.
Ich habe noch eine rechtliche Frage.
Raphad6397 schreibt:
Die Frage an dich: Ist das so?
Kann man z.B. von Thailand
oder Spanien aus arbeiten
oder wäre das ein Problem?
Ich bin kein Jurist,
aber das hörte ich
auch schon öfter von Unternehmen.
Dass aus arbeits- oder
versicherungstechnischen Gründen
nicht erlaubt wurde,
vom Ausland aus zu arbeiten.
Man will dort
eine gewisse Vorsicht walten lassen.
Aber es gibt noch eine andere
Komponente als die rein juristische.
Und zwar diejenige der Wirkung.
Wenn du dich vom Strand aus
ins Büro zuschaltest,
mag das bei ZEAM funktionieren,
wo man sich auf so etwas geeinigt
hat und es für alle okay ist.
Aber für ein grösseres Unternehmen
oder ein Unternehmen,
wo manche Leute gezwungenermassen
immer am selben Ort arbeiten müssen,
weil es nicht anders geht,
löst das schnell Neid aus.
Dann gibt es
erst recht grössere Diskussionen
und ein gewisses Gefälle unter den
Mitarbeitenden einer Organisation.
Und das wird dann auch schwierig.
Vielen Dank, das waren alle
Kommentare, die ich ausgesucht habe.
Danke, hast du dir Zeit genommen.
- Gerne, danke dir.
Tschüss, Konrad.
- Tschüss, Michèle.
Das war's vom "Q&A".
Vielen Dank fürs Zuschauen.
Danke auch für
die vielen Kommentare und Feedbacks,
für die lieben Worte,
die kritischen Stimmen.
Das hat mich sehr gefreut.
Einen Kommentar möchte ich
zum Schluss noch mit euch anschauen,
denn den fand ich sehr cool.
Valeriov4523 schreibt, wobei er
sich wohl auf die Workation bezieht:
Das fand ich super.
So sind alle halt etwas anders.
Vielen Dank fürs Zuschauen,
bis zum nächsten Mal.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
Florian Schuler - 2023